I am old enough to remember when the
word radical was surfer bro lingo and
not used to characterize any Muslim
committing a violent crime in fact we
used to talk about radicals we meant
these guys and now we mean these guys
and sometimes we're afraid that includes
all of them too but what makes a radical
today anyway well here's the biggest
open secret about radicalization it
doesn't exist
whoa Center you can't see that what you
can't just say that radicalization
doesn't exist blue what about all those
people who are threatening the
democratic bedrock of our country and
freedom the GOP presidential candidates
know these guys according to Wikipedia
where we get all our 101 information
anyway let's be real radicalization is
the process by which an individual comes
to have extreme political social or
religious beliefs that are anti status
quo but when we talk about
radicalization we don't mean these guys
we Muslims
no one asked where was he radicalized
when a white dude goes on a shooting
spree in a school or a theater white men
have been responsible for 64% of mass
shootings in this country since 1982 and
they get the privilege of being alone
wolf shooters or mentally ill shooters
or alienated and adrift shooters there's
all much talk about how even the US
government has said that the real
domestic threat to national security our
right-wing anti-government groups and
the president isn't telling white people
that there hasn't been enough pushback
against extremism in their communities
Wow the comments section is hella gonna
call you racist for that and there's no
set criteria for what the process of
radicalization even looks like or what a
radical actually is with the Boston
bombers we obsessed over tamerlan's our
nerves
to history with the Paris attackers we
obsessed over gay bars alcohol implied
promiscuity and with San Bernardino's
saved Rizwan Farook and tashfeen Malik
we obsessed over mullick becoming more
and more religious
so is radicalization being religious or
not is it having anti u.s. foreign
policy views is it being isolated from
society in the u.s. who can't be
prosecuted for your speech even if your
views are extreme and really gross
except in very specific part to prove
cases so yeah the Constitution protects
your right to be a Nazi to say
anti-black crap it even protects your
right to advocate for consensual love
between a grown man and a child because
views aren't actions actions can be
criminal but views nope and continuing
to talk about radicalization without any
set criteria and targeting only Muslims
when we talk about radicalization makes
anything and everything that Muslims do
suspect so you get programs like CVE you
get surveillance in mosques homes
businesses you get 15,000 informants
nationwide and you get a community that
has some serious trust issues and then
we get shocked that we have presidential
candidates openly calling for patrols in
Muslim neighborhoods from banning
Muslims from the country and issuing
special IDs to Muslims why do you say
that like it's a bad thing so maybe it's
time to rethink the poorly defined
language that we use and how that poorly
defined language creates programs
policies and dangerous misunderstandings
that have an effect on the lives of
millions in this country how's that for
a radical idea